hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a for
kids and others i was off
a little bit in previous weeks because
we were doing our annual
collection of summer programs our summer
school
and summer camp for high school students
and um
the result of that is we got more than
100 very interesting
original projects got done um towards my
time of year for taking things that i've
wondered about
all year and uh actually
seeing if they can move forward with uh
other
people working on them and i was very
satisfying this year
right we have a bunch of questions um
saved up here gosh where to start
um
there was a question here about
um neuroscience from
cambridge is programming
essential for the next breakthrough in
neuroscience both theoretical and
practical
uh how some of the things i've built how
might they contribute to that
well let's talk about what neuroscience
is
what a breakthrough would consist of
and try and take it from there so
neuroscience is kind of about how brains
work
and it's sort of it's only been a
hundred and
or so years that we've known that brains
have
neurons in them we have whatever it is
around um
100 billion neurons in our brains each
neuron each nerve cell
is this uh thing that's that's i don't
know how long maybe a few millimeters
long
and often maybe even longer than that um
it's it's like a tiny little piece of
wire
that has sort of electrical that um
uh can produce an electrical signal
and it has these um uh um dendrites at
one end
this whole kind of tree of of different
um little
little branches of of nerve cell that
kind of collect
in a sense the electrical signals and
then when they've collected enough
electrical signals
the nerve cell will fire and it will
produce an electrical signal that it
will then distribute to other nerve
cells through its so-called axons
and this is kind of the the picture of
sort of what brains are made of is this
very
complicated tangle of neurons nerve
cells
and that uh where the nerve cells are
ultimately getting
uh glucose get they're getting they're
getting
sort of fuel to be able to act like
little tiny battery-like
things where when they get signals
coming in
they can produce an electrical pulse
that goes out
and they're doing that oh it depends on
exactly what's happening in that part of
the brain but they might do that a
thousand times a second
every millisecond or so and most often
what they do is they produce these
so-called spike trains
where a particular nerve cell is like
going firing fiery fire and fire and
firing then it's
kind of quiescent for a while doesn't do
anything for a while and it's like
firing firing firing
again and uh one can now for
for probably what is it um 40 50 years
now
it's been possible to record from single
cells
um in brains not human brains because
you don't want to do that
typically it's for example the squid has
a giant axon
very big piece of it's it's some nerve
cells
and so it's particularly easy to record
from that
cats mice um these kinds of things
occasionally monkeys
um it's possible to record from single
cells in their brains
and to try and get a sense of what's
going on and what you get from that
single cell recording is mostly
just a lot of well it didn't do anything
and then suddenly it's very active and
so on
okay a big breakthrough was made i guess
in the 1960s
was the realization that there were sort
of correlations between
what the brain is experiencing and
what you can actually measure in the
electrical activity in the brain
so it had been known for much longer
than that that there's this eeg
this overall kind of pattern of
electrical activity in the brain
that's around 10 times a second or
something 10 cycles a second roughly
there are these overall kind of waves of
activity in the brain
and that's what you know when you put
electrodes on your on your head
that's what you're measuring is the eeg
um this
electroencephalogram this kind of
overall electrical activity in the brain
and for example when you're awake
there's one pattern of electrical
activity
if you go to sleep a different pattern
of electrical activity starts up and in
different phases of sleep
you see different kinds of patterns and
so on and
you know if you're unfortunate enough to
have for example an epileptic cesium
that shows up it's often very hard to to
tell exactly what's going on
but it shows up as this kind of
large-scale electrical activity
that affects large pieces of the brain
and it's not it's kind of like uh like a
computer
where instead of all the individual
transistors and so on they're all doing
the things that are processing
information
it's like there's a giant electrical
wave that goes through the computer
which is not very useful for information
processing
and in the case of humans uh can cause
seizures and so on so
the and you know typical they're
different kinds of seizures but but sort
of a typical thing is
sort of you know lots of muscles just
bouncing around randomly so to speak
because
those parts of the brain that are being
electrically stimulated sort of at
random in some sense
and i should explain that that you know
the brain is this
big bundle of 100 billion nerve cells
but you know we have
nerves that come out of the brain
through the spinal cord and so on
that uh feed into all the muscles
and sensors and so on throughout our
bodies and there are typically pretty
long
nerves that go down our arms and so on
and they're they're sort of places where
those nerves have kind of repeater
stations where the signal
propagates down one nerve one long nerve
and then it'll get to the next sort of
the junction box
and then it'll propagate down the next
nerve and so on it takes
about a tenth of a second to uh i think
that's
right well i mean the the overall
reaction time if you like see a light
and you have to press a button
is around one third of a second
typically um and
some fraction of that time is spent
actually sending the nerve signal down
down your arm to to your finger and then
what will happen is
you there's an electrical signal and the
nerve
that connects to the muscle in your
finger and the that electrical signal
when
when a muscle at the neuromuscular
junction
when when the nerve kind of has an
electrical
delivers uh sort of a little electric
shock to the muscle
um that little electric shock causes the
muscle to contract
um and of course when you get a big
electric shock
the one of the bad things that happens
is it causes all your muscles there to
contract
you know very violently and that's
that's a bad thing but
um the so
you know what we kind of already kind of
know the brain is
doing is it's causing muscles to move
and things like that
and it's receiving signals from all of
our sort of sensors all the touch
sensors the pain sensors
heat sensors all those kinds of things
that uh cover
our our bodies um both in some cases
externally and internally
um but we we've kind of known for a long
time that
you know in the end when we're going to
move our finger there's an electrical
signal that's generated in our brains
that eventually uh causes the muscle in
our fingers to move
okay the thing that was discovered i
guess in the 1960s was sort of the other
way around when when signals come into
the brain
what actually uh uh you know how
are they how are they kind of decoded in
the brain and so the big thing that was
discovered
at first is about vision and it's like
when you show something in the visual in
one's visual field
what actually happens in one's brain so
the first thing that happens is
light falls on the retina at the back of
our eyes and
in the retina when a photon of light uh
kind of
goes into one of these photoreceptor
cells at the back of our eye
it causes an electrical signal to be
generated in that cell
that electrical signal is then
transferred to the optic nerve
and the optic nerve then sends that data
about that
piece of light into our brains what does
it do well
in a somewhat piece of slightly bizarre
design uh the the optic nerves from our
eyes actually cross over in the center
of our heads
and go to the optic the the primary
visual cortex which is at the back of
the brain
sort of seems like bad design because it
seems like it would make more sense to
have the visual cortex
at the front uh near the eyes so you
don't have to have
the sort of trunk line going through the
brain and the slightly bizarre crossover
of right eye connects to the left part
of the um
well primarily to the left part of the
visual primary visual
cortex so
the um actually it's more complicated
than that it connects
eventually to both sides but it um
uh the the sort of this initial
crossover in
of the optic nerves inside the brain at
a thing called the lateral geniculate
nucleus which is just one of these
little features inside the brain
well in this case the um uh
let's see the the so the thing that was
observed is the following
so you show some pattern
in in the eyes and the question is what
kind of electrical signal does that
produce in the visual cortex
well so in in cats and monkeys i think
um these things were were explicitly
measured
and the the sort of the big thing that
was found is that there were certain
cells
that when you show the cat vertical
stripes
those cells will be like firing firing
firing all the time when you show the
cat horizontal stripes
those cells will be firing firing firing
all the time and
there are other cells that are sort of
center surround cells where you show the
the
something which is like like a little
picture of an eye actually where it's
sort of black in the middle white on the
outside
there's cells that are really excited
about that particular kind of
uh signal and so in general
the um uh what was discovered is that
there are certain
kinds of visual stimuli that
there are particular cells in the visual
cortex
that respond to those particular visual
stimuli and that was sort of
a big moment in neuroscience the
realization
that you could really map between actual
stimuli types of stimuli
and things that happen in the brain and
there was a lot more complexity there
for example the fact that we have stereo
vision
from two eyes we're kind of synthesizing
the the what we see out of our two
different eyes
and using that because from you know you
look at an object with each different
eye
you see a slightly different angle on
that object particularly if the object
is near to you
and that's what we use part of what we
use to figure out how far away an object
is
and that all happens in our physical
cortex
as sort of the signals from the two eyes
are kind of
combined together and so it's a funny
pattern because
the in the end there's this sort of
interdigitation this kind of fingers
come together
sort of fingers of of of of of
stimulation from the left eye and from
the right eye
that all sort of come together in the
visual cortex and the visual cortex
is what figures out somehow this
kind of stereo effect that we see
so that the basic picture of what's
happening is
at the the sort of a first layer of
neurons in the visual cortex
which picks out certain features like
vertical stripes horizontal stripes
sort of blobs with surroundings things
like this
and then we go to and then there are
subsequent layers it seems in
the in the brain in the visual cortex
that
are dealing with sort of larger and
larger scale features of pictures
and are kind of dealing with um uh sort
of analyzing
the bigger picture so to speak well
that so that's sort of a part of kind of
the the low levels of
of neuroscience that was sort of a big
realization that you could really
identify those kinds of of cells there
and such like now meanwhile the sort of
the
if you say well what's the big question
neuroscience
it's kind of like how does all the
thinking we do actually work
and so another big tool that came online
uh well let's see there was some work on
it in the 1980s but i think it really
came online
last 20 years or so uh first there were
things called evoked potentials
where you
try to measure sort of brain activity
associated with
a particular stimulus and you repeat the
stimulus and you try and detect
or without the stimulus you see very
little and with the stimulus you see
this thing
you try and do sort of on off
measurements to try and tease out was
there a small effect associated with
that stimulus
the more recently functional mri imaging
so this is imaging of essentially
the um uh well let's see you can image
uh well mri is is um
uh primarily looking at hydrogen so
water
um the activity now i'm a little bit
confused actually about how that works
but you're
you're ultimately looking at metabolic
activity parts of the brain
where there are nerve cells that are
firing and so they're using up glucose
and things like that
and i'm as i'm thinking about it right
now i'm not immediately
remembering how that exactly uh flows
through
from from the the way that the mri
imaging works but in any case the end
result is
you can kind of tell which parts of the
brain are sort of being active
and you can do that kind of in real time
although
you have to be inside a big mri machine
to be able to measure those things
and so there are endless experiments
that people do kind of showing
different kinds of stimuli different
kinds of objects
saying different words these kinds of
things and trying to see
what exact piece of the brain kind of
lights up
in response to that particular stimulus
and one of the things that's been
long a bit controversial is to what
extent is it the case that there's a
very definite signature that you can
kind of see from that mri
what is the person thinking maybe not
between different people but for a
particular person
oh there's the piece of the brain that
lights up when you think of a dog
there's another piece that lights up
when you think of a cat does that really
work
you know how solid is that kind of data
that's been one of the things that
endless endless experiments have been
done on
in neuroscience in the last 20 years or
so and i i'm
not sure i've uh to me it seemed a
little bit still a little bit unclear
just how
uh how sharply you can understand those
kinds of things
but then the other big thing so another
big sort of thing in neuroscience
has been this idea about sort of the
overall architecture of the brain
the overall uh well i should say a
couple of things
the brain is complicated it has many
complicated pieces in very low and very
simple organisms organisms where
the brain only has a couple of hundred
neurons in it for example
the precise configuration of those
neurons is the same
for every member of the species those
the precise configuration is determined
by the growth of the organism
and you know exactly where each nerve
cell is going to go and one nerve cell
will be responsible for this sort of
tentacle at the front of the organism
one nerve cell will be responsible for
carrying data from
you know the the light detector in the
organism to this and
it's all a very simple it's a circuit
where you can essentially trace every
wire in the circuit
when it comes to us humans the
individual placement of neurons is not
determined
it's uh uh it's just oh there'll roughly
be a bunch of neurons here and then the
details of how those neurons fill in
is something that sort of just happens
it seems kind of almost at random
although it's not quite at random as we
develop
and for a long time people thought you
know you're born with a certain set of
neurons
and that's all you'll ever have and
there are neurons only die
and if you do crazy things more of them
will die but
um uh the uh but then
um it's uh uh it became clear
oh maybe 20 years ago now that actually
there was evidence that actually there
were new neurons that could be
uh could be produced in in an adult
brain so probably even somebody as
ancient as me is actually growing new
neurons
from time to time it's not clear what
will stimulate
the largest number of new neurons
growing and whether that's even a good
idea because
in a sense the neurons and the or the
junctions between neurons are what hold
our memories
and if you just introduce a bunch of new
neurons it's not clear what exactly that
does
in terms of what we can do or not do but
clearly if you lose neurons
that's that's a bad thing but any case
so
the brain the details of where each
neuron is placed those are not
determined
but the overall structure of brains is
determined to some extent they're you
know they're these overall patterns of
all these different
lobes and different structures in the
brain and so on
and they have certain general features
of what they tend to do the right side
of the brain does
does this the left side of the brain
does this the language center
well it's in different places in
different people's brains and so on
but there's sort of a general
organization of the brain
into different kinds of things and and
some parts of the brain
okay like where the visual cortex is
that's pretty fixed where the
the motor strip that that is where the
sort of initial signals from muscles
come from
that's fairly fixed and then some other
things move around a bit more
but i think the um uh the thing that
is just a lot of very complicated
structure in human brains i mean if one
thinks that
you know and brains are very variable
it's just like fingerprints vary
brains vary a lot more than fingerprints
they're sort of all folded up they're
kind of in in
layers and they're folded up and that
the patterns of folding
are very specific to individual people
so in any case there's a lot
that there is to figure out about sort
of the structure of the brain how things
are organized in the brain
uh how this or that piece of the brain
tends to react to this or that thing um
there are all sorts of situations in
which
uh people have uh different kinds of
problems in different parts of the brain
what effect does that have
to what extent can if one part of the
brain
is not being used what you expect like
because
somebody is visually impaired and so
they're not using their visual cortex
because their eyes are not sending
signals to it you know what does that
part of the brain end up getting used
for all those kinds of things a lot of
a lot of complicated things to figure
out there but
the other sort of big sort of story of
neuroscience is about
kind of how do brains really manage to
think
and back in the 1940s it was already
proposed that brains kind of think a bit
like machines
process information and there was this
analogy made between
sort of idealized models of computers
that hadn't there weren't yet
real electronic computers but there were
idealized ones and
and they were sort of it was like well
maybe that's kind of like how idealized
brains work and it's kind of like
electrical wires
and they're all connected and they have
different sort of logical operations
that they do as these wires meets and
cross and so on
and there was a sort of whole theory of
these things developed and one of the
big questions was
in that theory where is the memory a big
feature about
us is we remember stuff how do we
remember stuff well
the thing that was believed and still
believed is that memory
is associated with the synapses the
connections between
the axons and dendrites that are at the
sort of receiving and sending parts
of the um of of nerve cells
and so it's become clearer sort of in
more detail how that works with
particular sort of pores and channels in
these
uh synapses um that kind of can be
filled in or not filled in and so on
depending on that sort of how our
memories are stored
but this general idea of memories are
somehow stored in synapses
and somehow our experiences we learn
from our experiences and the experiences
determine those memories
the memories then determine sort of how
we do things we remember skills and
things like this
and it sort of gradually emerged that it
works kind of like computers work in the
sense that we are
storing code for how to do things and
we're storing
things that we remember facts scenes
images
whatever that we remember we're somehow
storing these things how is really that
how is that really organized
how does that really work well one
doesn't know for sure
the the thing that happened back in the
um early 1980s
was people where people had had this
idea back in the 1940s of neural
networks
this kind of electrical machine-like
network in the brain
and some ideas about how memories will
be formed of sort of when you've seen a
thing multiple times
it sort of strengthens the the memory
strengthens the connection between the
appropriate nerve cells
and so on and that's kind of how you
remember things but for various reasons
kind of the mathematics didn't work out
terribly well and people got kind of
convinced that
those kinds of neural nets couldn't do
anything interesting
so they kind of pulled back from that
then at the beginning of the 1980s
there was sort of a rebirth in these
things as computer experiments became
more realistic and so on
and people started saying oh well
actually we can get these artificial
neural nets
to do somewhat interesting things and so
there was this kind of renaissance of
interest in that
and that fed into neuroscience because
it was like well we can also do computer
simulations in neuroscience
and make some conclusions about how
actual brains work meanwhile we can use
these artificial neural networks
to do things technologically it didn't
pan out that well technologically there
were a few things that got done with
neural nets
for example when you optical character
recognition when you're recognizing this
is abcd
you know which which letter is it first
it was just digits
which of these 10 digits did somebody
hand write on a check that they wrote
or something like this that was
something that was successfully done
with neural nets
in the 1980s and it sort of became the
standard technology for doing those
kinds of things
but more elaborate tasks like saying
what's this a picture of of the
of the five or ten thousand things that
we have names for in english
the kind of picturable nouns of english
what's this a picture of you couldn't do
that
with artificial neural nets nobody had
figured out how to do that back in the
1980s
and 1990s and so on but a small set of
people kind of continued to work on the
idea
of having these sort of big artificial
neural nets and
training them to do complicated tasks a
bit like humans and finally
around 2011 there was kind of a
breakthrough in that almost accidental
breakthrough
that if you just do enough training
millions and millions of rounds of
training and so on
you can get these neural nets these
artificial neural nets
that are just represented in a computer
to actually learn
like 10 000 different kinds of object
that you could show to
to the neural net and do a pretty good
job identifying as a dog as
a cat and so on so that happened and
that led to the whole
kind of uh flowering of machine learning
and neural networks
that took place over more or less the
last 10 years um it's kind of a little
bit slowing down now
but a lot of different things like
recognizing objects
like being able to go from sounds to
uh to written text you know speech to
text
being able to do language translation uh
all these various kinds of things
being able to take an image and sort of
fill in just
fill in what you think should be there
even though there's a whole that's
something that our brains do
like you know in our eyes our optic
nerve
kind of has again in a piece of somewhat
questionable design
our optic nerve kind of makes a blind
spot on the kind of nose side of each
eye
so if you if you kind of close one eye
and you're looking at like a
thing of graph paper you put a big black
blob
on the graph paper there's a place where
if you're the right distance away and
you kind of focus on the thing
that black blob will just disappear
because that black blob is right at the
place where you have a blind spot in
your eye
it's where the optic nerve connects to
the to the retina of your eye
and um so you you don't see the the big
black blob
instead what you see is just a
continuation of the graph paper it's
like
how did that happen well the answer is
because brains
just our brains sort of recognize
patterns of what's going on
and they just try and fill in more of
the same and neural nets are also pretty
good at doing that
so probably in much the same ways that
our brains do it
but any case so this sort of revolution
of artificial neural nets took place
over the last 10 years or so
and at the the underlying sort of what
is easy to do in a computer for a neural
nets is not the same as what it's easy
to do in brains
um it's it's there are different kinds
of operations to do with
the way that particularly the way that
learning happens and uh this whole
kind of mechanism of back propagation
and and all these kinds of things
it seems very different from the way we
thought brains worked
what's become clear in recent years is
that not too surprisingly
now that we've really understood how
things work in artificial neural nets
a lot of the sort of core ideas can
actually be sort of
moved back into traditional neuroscience
even though
actual nerve cells don't quite work the
way that artificial neural nets work
but it seems like the overall
architecture is surprisingly similar
but so then the question is okay so what
is the sort of
the question that i was asked here was
about sort of breakthroughs in
neuroscience
neuroscience is a quite popular field a
lot of people who work on it
it's a field where there are a lot of
detailed things to do
and there are a lot of specific
experiments to do on
different kinds of animals and different
kinds of
parts of the brain and different sort of
kinds of stimuli and so on there's just
a lot to do a lot to figure out
the question might be what's the big
picture of what one wants to know
and is one for example trying to use
what one learns from the brain
to make better artificial intelligence
you know it's not obvious that's the
right way to get to better artificial
intelligence
it's like one could think as people did
150 years ago
that the right way to learn how to do
flight is to study birds
but in fact aeroplanes do not flap their
wings
they don't have feathers their work in a
different way
than birds work what is good for
engineering good for our sort of
engineering with aluminum and and jet
engines and things like that
is a little different from what's good
for a bird
that is just sort of trying to transport
itself and has certain ratios of
you know uh bone and strength to this
that and the other
it's um and has a different kind of
control system that airplanes have had
in the past although
those things are converging a bit more
now um but
uh so this question of how do you make
sort of the intelligent
thing it's not clear that
knowing more about brains helps you that
much with that
although what i think is true is that
there is sort of the abstract idea of
intelligence having nothing to do with
human intelligence
is not perhaps as useful as you might
think
a lot of the things we want a machine
that we interact with
to do are things that are very
human-like very human-oriented
and that's something for which more
knowledge of the brain might be more
useful
but i think if one asks sort of what is
the big question of neuroscience
i'm not sure i entirely know the answer
to that i think
one might hope that there's some sort of
grand theory
that tells one this is how brains work
but i think we know kind of how the
pieces of brains work we know how
we can learn from examples we know how
a bunch of kinds of processing of things
work
uh when we'll be able to get something
which has sort of the scale of a human
brain
when if one looks at sort of simulations
of how brains work so so another
question is can we simulate a whole
human brain
with 100 billion neurons can we just put
that on a computer
and have a big computer and have it
operate just like a human brain
not yet we're at the level of being able
to do
tiny little sort of uh tiny little
regions of the human brain um
but it's uh it's also a question of at
what level do you want to simulate it
because ultimately brains have all kinds
of details about you know
how much glucose got to that cell how
much energy could it really
expand does it you know is this
particular dendrite
does this have a little kink at the end
of it does it have a little spine that
sticks out in this place or that place
the thing that isn't obvious is which of
those things actually matter
as far as the sort of information
processing thinking parts of brains
is concerned it's just like if you have
a computer and
you know there's a little scratch on the
outside of this cpu chip or something
does it matter does it not matter or if
there's a little you know in
a little piece of the channel in the
silicon um of the microprocessor chip
oh there's a little extra wave in this
place does it matter does it not matter
so what we've learned the big thing
about digital computers
is that in a digital computer it's
either there's a one
or a zero it could be the case that
there's a point zero one point zero two
point zero three
there's little sort of gray gradations
of um
of amounts of let's say memory uh
something where instead of saying
i remember the answer is 0 1 0 it would
be well it's
it's sort of roughly 0.2.8.3 or
something
well it's not precisely digitally 0 1 0
it's something more sort of vague and uh
and sort of smoothly varying
between 0 and 1 for example so one of
the things that
that became clear from neurons is well
in digital computers
the big thing is we force all the data
to be zero or one
and if it's just if if something happens
electrically that causes something to be
.02 or something it'll just be kicked
down to zero
it's just like no it can't be point zero
two it's gotta be just zero
unless it's one it's zero so to speak
and so
that's kind of the approach of digital
electronics and that means that
little amounts of noise little amounts
of sort of perturbations kicking around
of these values that's all ignored
because it's all squashed to being
either zero or one
and one of the things that got learnt
actually it was guests back in the 1940s
um is that brains actually have a
similar kind of trick when you have
nerve cells when you have a certain
amount of input certain amount of input
nothing much happens it's kind of like a
zero
and then suddenly above some other input
boom it becomes one
so brains kind of have this digital
trick digital idea built into them
and that kind of suggests that certain
kinds of noise certain kinds of
imperfections
might not be important to brains and
that means that
this question of at what level do you
need to model the brain to reproduce
kind of its information processing
capabilities
we don't entirely know the answer to
that yet some people think it may matter
what you know the microtubules on the
surface of of nerve cells are doing
other people think that's totally
irrelevant and it's only the very large
scale structure of nerve cells that
matters
and so on so it's not completely clear
so it's not completely clear
sort of how big a computer we would need
to simulate a brain
at what level of of uh correctness so to
speak
but there will come a time when we can
do a pretty decent job of simulating
a brain at a decent level of precision
so to speak
and at what point will we then be able
to kind of train the brain
the simulated brain like we train our
own brains
are probably it'll happen um the only
issue is
the details of what we learn have to do
with our interaction with the world
so for example when we trained our first
image identifier thing that recognizes
dogs and cats and
elephants and uh teacups and all these
kinds of things
we showed it oh how many was it i think
maybe 30 million images
and we realized that that number of
images is pretty comparable
to the number of images a young kid sees
in the first few years of their life
and that's kind of you know what we had
to train our neural net with
was comparable to what a human would see
as they sort of wander around the world
in the first few years of life
an important feature of what humans seem
to do is
like you poke at something and you see
what happens and that's kind of how you
learn
how the world works in some sense and
that to do that kind of poking and
seeing what happens
about the world at a sort of human level
you almost have to be sort of a humanoid
robot
that's about the size of humans and has
fingers and sort of has an experience of
the world that's based on poking at
things with fingers and
all those kinds of things and so it's
not clear how much of that stuff has to
be there
for it to be possible for even a brain
emulating
sort of thing to learn the same way that
our brains learn
and you know if the thing is just
sitting as a box on your desk and has a
different experience of the world
it's going to learn somewhat different
things but so that's
sort of the question of will we be able
to sort of emulate how brains work the
answer is i think
pretty definitely yes will we then have
a global theory of neuroscience a theory
of how brains work that's not so clear
because it could be as happens a lot
with neural networks right now
is you can train the neural network to
do this or that thing but if you say
how does it work how does it tell a cat
from a dog
and and you know what is the thing that
makes it decide that's a cat that's a
dog
that's a hard thing to know and you can
do some kinds of measurements inside
neural nets to say
this is the region that's activated to
make it decide it's going to be cat-like
rather than dog-like and so on
but in general it's a hard thing to
describe and
a lot of it just ends up being well
there's a million neurons in here
and they have this very detailed pattern
of behavior and at the end of the day
it's kind of going to conclude cat or
dog so
there may not be a kind of larger scale
story where you just say
well okay the reason the way it tells
cats from dogs is by how pointy the ears
are
and whether the whiskers work in this
way or that way there may not be kind of
a
a large-scale narrative story you can
tell and it may not be possible to have
in neuroscience
a sort of large-scale story you can tell
about kind of how
that struck how the brain processes the
information to come up with a conclusion
you can you can look at some pieces of
how that works and maybe some overall
workflow of what's happening
but it's not obvious that there'll be
sort of a step-by-step
this is how it works narrative that you
can tell this is something that's come
out of
of science that i've done about this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility
that even when you know the rules by
which your system operates
it may not be that you can tell a sort
of big story about what the system is
doing
it may just be you have to say well this
nerve cell causes this nerve cell
causes this nerve cell and there may be
no sort of human understandable bigger
story to tell
and of course there are things one can
ask you know in when it comes to human
language
there are lots of kinds of questions
about sort of how does that work how do
we understand human language
when we construct a sentence you know
it's got subject
verb object in english and there's this
whole kind of tree of different
subclauses in a sentence how do we in
our brains
pick apart those subclauses and kind of
understand the sentence
you know we do a good job of
understanding
natural language in wolframalpha for
example
when people are typing all kinds of
things in and we're trying to understand
what does that mean
we're trying to convert that into our
internal computational language
now in brains it's a little bit unclear
what you're converting
the data into so to speak you hear these
words
you can tell oh you know this this is a
subclause of that and so on
but what is the what's the target we
don't really understand that
and brains presumably one question is
can we describe that target
is there a reasonable human way to
describe that target
or is it something where the only thing
we can say is well we gradually learn
over the course of our lives
this very complicated pattern that is
the thing
that where we have certain rules that
are operating on our neurons
that in the end lead us to do the things
we do based on the things based on the
language we hear
but there isn't really a sort of bigger
story to tell in how that language is
interpreted
just as there isn't really a bigger
story to tell when we look at one of
these
computer simulations and we're seeing
all these different uh
individual rules behaving in certain
ways and then there's some result from
that
so there's sort of a question of what
what might the answer look like
if we solve that problem what would the
solution be like
would the solution be and i think this
is probably the answer
sort of a higher level theory for what's
happening in the brain
that is beyond this individual neuron
does that and
below just when you understand what the
english sentence means
it's something intermediate that's sort
of telling you the mechanism for that
and it's not really clear quite what
that will look like
i mean to me that's much more like a
kind of
question of of uh well okay so so one of
the things i've spent
well much of my life doing is trying to
find sort of computational ways to
describe
how things in the world work to have a
sort of computational language
that can describe the geometry of how
things are placed or the sounds that are
produced or
or facts about chemistry or molecules or
whatever else
and so one of the questions would be is
there a way of sort of
turning what is happening in a brain
into something which can be described in
computational language
interesting question i don't really know
the answer
people have tried to use mathematics to
describe what happens in the brain
that's not been very successful
mathematics as it's currently configured
saying
you know we have these mathematical
equations and things there aren't really
good equations for the brain
it's just not a good way to describe the
brain when we deal with sort of
specific programs for individual neurons
we can do pretty well for that
we can sort of aggregate that up to okay
what are 10 million neurons going to do
but we tend to be at the level of these
are the detailed things that 10 milli
neurons are doing
not at the level of tell me the sort of
larger scale computational description
of what's happening
so i think that's uh as i think about it
that's probably
if you were to ask what is what would
the future of neuroscience look like
in a perfect world it's well we'd have a
theory of neuroscience what's the theory
going to be stated in terms of
in what we have looked to sometimes in
the in the past in the exact sciences
is some sort of mathematical theory an
equation of the brain i don't think
we're going to get that
will we get a computational language for
the brain we might
we might that's a much more reasonable
thing to think about
and it's something where it may be the
case there isn't really a good
computational language
because we can describe the low-level
neuron operations but then we just say
oh and put 10 million of them together
and this is the details of what happens
and we don't get to sort of say
more uh in in in more kind of human
understandable way
a sort of higher level description of
what's happening but i think that's
probably where
one might be going with that and it's an
interesting question
what that sort of intermediate
computational language for the brain
might look like and i actually have seen
almost no work on that at all
so it's an interesting question and i
haven't really
formulated it quite like that before but
that would be a
probably the thing to kind of be
thinking about um in terms of
uh sort of a target for neuroscience
it's just like when we understand
natural language and wealth and alpha
as i say it's not just uh let's
abstractly understand what somebody
means when they say
what's the population of boston divided
by united states
what what you know it's not a question
of sort of abstractly
light bulb goes off we understood it's a
question of converting that into
uh you know entity united states
population
you know the the function divide applied
to that and another entity of this
it's converting that into this
computational language which has a
precisely defined
meaning that can be computed on by a
computer so to speak
with our world from language technology
stack um
that's what it means to understand
natural language
and so similarly what it would mean to
sort of understand how brains work
is to say let's convert this
yes there's low-level operations that
are kind of the machine code of how the
brain is working
there are all these neurons firing and
all these kinds of things and there's an
overall story which is
and then we see a cat or something but
the question is is there a
sort of computational language version
of a higher level story
about oh then there's this kind of
filter that's applied and
and this thing that happens and there's
sort of a higher level story about
what's happening
and uh that's something which implicitly
some of the architectures for neural
nets
that exist now uh have sort of
aspects like attention layers and things
of let's pay attention to a particular
part of the image
let's these convolutional layers where
you're you're like do the things which
very similar to the early processing
in our visual cortex of things like
identifying stripes and spots and all
these kinds of things
and those we can sort of understand what
they're doing the intermediate levels of
processing
we don't understand so well it's
probably a reasonable formulation to say
is there a sort of computational
language that we can give that describes
those kind of intermediate layers
all right that was a very long answer to
that um
uh question
um
let's see there's a little bit more on
brains so let me let me ask
let me talk a little bit about brains
there's a question from robert here
about
smart drugs custom-made neuropeptides
that um increase i don't know what this
is
um i probably should know some some
brain function
kind of measure i'm always
brains are complicated i you know if you
say let's just throw in this thing
and uh uh like you know typical
whether it's eating caffeine or
chocolate or
or drinking alcohol or whether it's
taking some other kind of drug
these are very sort of coarse hammers
that you hit brains with and what effect
that has
is often very hard to know and you know
some of these things we kind of know it
increases the level of this
neurotransmitter this particular
substance associated with
the transmission of information from one
neuron to the next
um and there's a few neurotransmitters
that
have certain overall levels in the brain
and when their levels vary
different things happen and so on i
think there are
sort of hopes and there have been
forever and ever that you can just sort
of take this pill
and you'll be smarter as a result
i find that a little bit hard to
to get into i think that
you know one's experience is oh well if
one's tired
there's certain kinds of things that one
doesn't figure out
but i think that's more a question of
one's degree of attentiveness and
tenacity and
you know how long can one really stick
with it or is one like i just want to go
to sleep
um and uh you know i think that's more
than whether the intrinsic
processing is is happening i do know
that
that some things slow down when one gets
tired once reactions slow down
things like this so i don't really know
all of those dynamics
and i suppose one could imagine uh
there's some way to just sort of
speed things up um i i suspect you know
and some drugs are said to do that
um i think uh um well my own personal
uh i would never touch any of those
things myself
but that's that may be more of a
personal statement about um
i just think it's a very complicated
setup and i don't um
these hammers seem dangerous to
to deploy so to speak but uh
what would it mean to sort of be smarter
you know is there a a notion of that uh
you know for example for me as
you know one one when i think about
problems and it's like can i solve this
problem can i figure this out
there's a lot of dimensions to that
there's a lot of do i remember related
things
can i recognize the thing i've been
confronted with is related to something
i was confronted with before
when i think through things it might
take me hours to figure something out
and it's like well couldn't i be smarter
and just get to the end without going
through all those intermediate steps
not obvious given what one knows it's
not obvious
sometimes that you can avoid those steps
it could be the case that yes if you
already knew the answer great you can
get to the answer at the end that's not
really
a question of sort of being smarter well
maybe it is
it's just a question of knowing more and
it's certainly you know my personal
experience has been
the more you know the easier it is to
figure stuff out
um because there's more likelihood that
some question that you're confronted
with
is like well i've seen something a
little bit like that before let me grab
this piece of knowledge from here
or this methodology from here and let me
apply it to the thing that i'm now
thinking about i mean that seems very
effective
i kind of am i'm deeply dubious about
the kind of uh
you know take the smart pill and then
you'll be able to do things better
because for example one of the things
that could happen
is you know one of the bad things could
happen is like well
you know one of the things one needs to
do is to figure out what's connected to
what
well let's say you you know take the
pill that makes it
easier for your brain to connect this to
that well one of the things that can
happen is like oh my gosh
your brain is just completely you know
inundated with this is connected this is
connected this is connected
you know that uh thing that's there it
reminds me of a
an oyster and that other thing that's
there reminds me
of a uh a charging rhinoceros and that
other thing reminds me of this and
you know pretty soon you'll be you
there's this high level of noise of just
kind of
all these different things that are
rushing in and so it's a tricky thing
you need
just enough kind of uh ability to
connect things but not
so much there's just this huge noise
level of all these connections that
almost certainly don't make sense
and yet not so little that you just say
oh i've never seen anything like that
before
kind of thing so i think it's a you know
these are subtle things and i'm
i'm skeptical about any kind of uh big
hammer being able to
to have much good effect there
um
it's a question from david about crick
mitchuson theory of rem
sleep well i i knew francis crick
slightly and i knew graham mitcheson's
somewhat too um however i'm not sure
that i'm well acquainted with their
theory of rem sleep i think that
what that has to do with is the idea
that
during rapid eye motion sleep which is
one of the phases of sleep happens every
let's see i should know because i've
seen that sleep trace for myself a
zillion times it happens
a few times a night you go through these
periods of rem sleep i
maybe if you're younger it happens more
often and um
these are the periods when
it might be the case that you are kind
of consolidating memories
and there might be things you learnt
during the day and you kind of
you're kind of working through those
things you learnt and i think it is
probably the case
that a lot of what we remember is not
the thing that originally happened but
our memory of the thing that originally
happened
our sort of rehearsal of the you know
how we remember remembering what
happened so to speak
and i it could very well be the case
that that during that phase of sleep
we are remembering we're sort of doing
the first level of remembering the
second level of remembering so to speak
and that that helps develop sort of
longer term memories but i i don't
uh um i'm not um
actually i have heard about this in more
detail i probably could um uh
see this is a case where my memory is
not perfect i remember different things
that are sort of
related to this and conversations i had
and so on but i'm not sure that i can
completely put them together
quickly to to give a summary of what's
going on there but sort of an idea
that as you form long-term memories
because you know we have a
kind of short buffer memory that lasts a
few minutes where for example if
somebody says what were the last few
words i said
you can probably chop those out but you
won't remember those words permanently
typically
but there's something that happens over
the course of of hours today
or so that is part of our the the
creation of our long-term memory and
it's known
how that happens in terms of protein
synthesis and so on in
in synapses and there's a fair amount
that's known about how that actually
works now
and they're things that can interrupt
that long-term memory formation
and so on but that that's kind of what
happens and the role of sleep
in sort of making memories uh happen
is uh is is something still
still being investigated so to speak
all right let's see
um oh boy
all right we've got a question here
uh about something i don't know much
about from frost can i comment on the
history of plant breeding
and computation or agriculturalist
technology
it seems that old plant breeders think
that new molecular breeding techniques
are a waste of time and money
modern breeders use genomic selection
with snips and all kinds of things
and this is partly related to
genetically modified crops and so on
so okay the the question is
let's say you want to grow a grape that
doesn't have seeds
let's say you want to grow a bigger
juicier strawberry
let's say you want to grow a corn plant
that has a higher yield that produces
more corn
per amount of per number of plants or
something how do you make that happen
well what people realized now
uh well a long time ago but but
more intensely maybe a couple of 150
years ago or so
was that you could really do uh plant
breeding
that is you could say okay i've got
i i make these um these strawberry
plants
and i'm going to have a whole row of
strawberry plants and the strawberry
plant that makes the biggest juiciest
strawberry
out of this collection i'm going to take
that one and i'm going to use that to
produce the next generation of
strawberry plants
and i'm going to throw out all those
loser strawberry plants that made little
tiny strawberries
and so i'm going to keep going and i
keep iterating through many generations
tens of generations or more iterating
and saying okay at every generation
let me pick the biggest juiciest
strawberries and that's
kind of the idea of artificial selection
of
kind of of breeding things to achieve a
particular purpose and people have done
that with animals for a long time
and in a sense for example charles
darwin's idea of natural selection from
1859 or so
was this idea that this notion of
picking out
the biggest juiciest strawberry or
something can happen not artificially by
us breeding it and saying we're going to
pick
the plant with the biggest juicy
strawberry but naturally
through the fact that the plant with
let's say the biggest juiciest
strawberry
is the one that is going to naturally
have the most progeny
because i'm just making it up for that
case because it's the one that more
animals eat and so the seeds get spread
more
more widely or something or in general
with natural selection it's like
there are different traits that occur
you know this bird has a beak
that allows it to crack certain kinds of
nuts that occur
in the environment where it lives and as
the beak gets longer and pointier
it can crack the nuts better and so that
bird will naturally
end up surviving better and having more
more
bird children so to speak and um so
the idea of artificial selection is to
do that sort of by hand
to say rather than letting nature pick
what's the most successful organism
what's the one that can find the most
food produce the most
uh you know children so to speak
um we'll do that by hand we'll decide
this is the pigeon we think looks nicest
this is the dog
we think has the nicest uh um
you know nicest floppy ears or whatever
and so will uh
whatever is this is the plant that gets
the smallest or largest or whatever
we will artificially select these things
out that's the traditional
idea of plant breeding and that's the
thing that led
maybe 100 years ago now to um
uh dramatically improved agricultural
yields
people have thought 150 years ago and so
people were saying gosh you know at that
time the population of the world might
have been
half a billion a billion people people
were saying there's no way we can
support two billion people
you know we're just going to run out of
food because if we plant
crops across all the fields across the
whole earth
they just won't be we won't have enough
yield of actual
sort of food from these crops to be able
to feed a larger population
well the reason one of the principal
reasons that didn't
come to pass that we didn't run out of
food is because
the yield of crops got dramatically much
better
through crop breeding basically and
through
i don't know all the history i think
there was a crop called alfalfa which
was one of the
one of the sort of bread crops that was
um
uh very successful but in any case i
don't know that history well so
so somebody has to look that up to be
sure um i think that
um the uh
but the the main point was that the
original
what crops naturally produced per acre
in terms of food was able to be
dramatically improved by crop breeding
and there were oh various parts of the
world where people didn't believe in
crop breeding for various ideological
reasons and terrible things happened and
all sorts of funny things but basically
that was
a um uh that was kind of a a notion of
of um how so that that
led to to sort of much more efficient
crops
now the thing that's happened more
recently is explicit genetic engineering
you take the genome of such and such a
plant
and you just say let's go in in a lab
and just change that part of the genome
let's change that piece of the genome to
be more resistant to
various kinds of pests or something or
let's change that piece of the genome
to produce this or that um
kind of uh um this or that effect
and uh so i've kind of my sort of joke
thing about genetically modified crops
is
uh i want to see a time when we
understand enough about genetics
that we're able to like print a barcode
on a tomato or something
by virtue by when i say print grow a
barcode on a tomato
that the genome of the tomato will
actually uh
be so carefully organized that as the
tomato develops
somewhere the pigmentation of the tomato
will correspond to a barcode and so you
just take it to the checkout and
and somebody can um i you know i think
the technology
of recognizing a tomato is probably
coming much sooner and it's
here now probably than the technology of
being able to genomically
um put a grow a tomato with a barcode on
it
so that's kind of a joke thing actually
back in oh i
i had a let's say an acquaintance
who was well-known scientist who who had
um
uh the theory back in the 1960s he used
to say
you know all the stuff with computers
it's all irrelevant
what's really going to happen is that
biology genetic engineering
is going to be the thing that makes us
able to build
things that do tasks we want and i think
that led
that kind of idea led to some you know
science fiction movies
where people had sort of uh where there
was sort of a portrayal of genetics
hackers
where the genetics hacker instead of
having if it was an electronics hacker
they might have set up all kinds of
electronic circuits that would you know
open their door when this or that person
showed up or whatever else but instead
in some of these science fiction movies
they're little creatures that are
special purpose creatures that you know
open the door when they see such and
such a person coming or whatever
well that didn't happen the sort of
genetic engineering
of like animals like that didn't happen
um
i think that's not the level at which we
understand for actually much of the same
reasons as the things i was talking
about in neuroscience
it's sort of not the level that we
currently understand biology
at of being able to we can do something
like make it a bigger strawberry
but we can't make it do something like
print the barcode on the on the
strawberry or the tomato
whatever else it is that's a level of
detail we we don't really understand and
the way that sort of
the processing of information works in
biological growth and so on
but any case the the sort of a big
debate
about genetically modified crops and oh
these are not naturally produced crops
they're not um they're they're sort of
produced very much in a lab
i think that um this whole question of
uh can bad things happen when you
produce stuff in labs you know it's a
big
big issue for our uh unfriendly
virus that you know i think is
is um uh you know i think the evidence
tends to suggest that it's sort of
something
that got produced in a lab um and uh
as a piece of research um about well
what happens if we make viruses like
this
um and unfortunately it sort of got out
and turns out it's pretty good at
infecting humans and things
and so one might say you know well
that's a potential problem
because you know we can say let's modify
a plant and say well let's modify it and
make this
change and uh what happens if you do
this and so on
and that could lead to bad consequences
and yes it is very hard to know
what the precise consequences of some
particular change are
i think that the things that tend to
happen in crops
tend to be a bit more benign than uh the
things that you can do with modifying
viruses
but it's still a um uh
you know it's something i think there's
some reason to be concerned about
although i would say that once concern
can get overblown
um i think that uh it's one of these
things where
it's a bit like i don't know testing of
anything
uh it's like when you write a piece of
software it's like
well i think i wrote the software and i
did it perfectly and it has no bugs in
it
well you can't know that you have to
test it
and you know when you do enough testing
you'll typically find
you know there's a good chance you'll
find all the bugs maybe there'll be one
that creeps through maybe in some
special situation
some sort of bug will jump out and and
bite you so to speak
and so it might be with with something
like uh genetically uh
modified crops um but it's
uh you know there are there are risks in
everything and there are also benefits
to
these things and you know the situations
in which you can get dramatically
more efficient more robust kinds of uh
things that make food and food is
something we we need everywhere around
the world
and it's not something where it's
probably the right calculation to say no
no
just because it doesn't have the
naturalness of having been
kind of bred by artificial selection
which is again not natural because
it's your picking which is the best
bestest fittest
strawberry or whatever it is um not
nature itself picking that and of course
nature itself picking it is again a very
circular kind of thing because
something like well you know there's a
there's a particular kind of organism
that is fitter because now there's a
road going through that part of
of of the countryside or whatever or
that organism is fitter because
it is something which humans think looks
cute
so they keep it as pets and so there are
more of it in the world
things like this i mean it's it's a
complicated uh
you know the ecosystem of these kinds of
things is pretty complicated
and i think it's not um uh it's not
something where there's a
definitive oh no you shouldn't do that
or oh yes that's a great idea
it's something where uh uh you know it's
it's
it's it's a complicated judgment issue
but i think um
uh yeah i don't know as much about
hybrids and
and um uh the the details of how crops
are are bred and so on to comment much
more on that
let's see
uh
well maybe i can do one or two more
questions here
um
as a question
i don't know how to take this um
there's a question here from vuk asking
about
will the future bring surveillance uh
all-knowing government
deep and can deep fakes and other things
be used to sort of fake
identity and physical and digital worlds
to sort of get rid of
people knowing sort of who you are boy
that's complicated
i mean i think that
this question of how do you know
who if you're dealing with a computer
and you're sort of on the internet how
do you know
who that is who's interacting with the
computer
for example do you even know if it's a
person you know on the internet nobody
knows if you're a bot
nobody knows if you're a cat randomly
typing on the computer keys
how do you tell that it's a person who
is
interacting with that website and there
are all these sort of tests of you know
click this button you know the button
sort of moves around and it's something
dynamically generated on a web page and
it's like if you can click it
if you can see where it is well then
that proves your humor well it doesn't
really because
you could have a program it's a little
tricky to do that because of the way web
browsers work and so on
that you can you can in principle make
something which recognizes where that
box is and clicks the button
well then there are captures where it
says you know
find the traffic lights in this picture
um
or it just says in simpler case it's
like here are some
letters you know we've made these things
a bunch using image processing in our in
our language
here these letters can use what you know
type in what these letters say
and the letters have been really
distorted and and pulled out
and made so that they're very hard to
recognize but
you know if we can do it uh
so can a bunch of our machine learning
systems and that's kind of an arms race
of you know can can the are there things
that humans can do there's no good
having a capture that says
let's confirm you're a human and then
the human is like well i just can't do
this
so uh you know that that's a complicated
sort of thing where
it should be just doable by the humans
but not doable by the current generation
of machine learning and that's a very
thin
thin maybe non-existent line and then
similarly there are these things like
find the traffic lights in this picture
i'm actually surprised that our current
machine learning tools can't do those
i haven't tried it recently my guess is
they probably can do them
my guess is that the trickiness is sort
of injecting all of that into the web
browser
and all those kinds of things but that's
just a detailed engineering thing
but this question of you know on the
internet can you even tell you're a
human
that's a that's an interesting question
uh it's you know can you tell what's at
the other end of that computer
so to speak well there are a lot of
things
people do for for example financial
services
you know your your your uh you know
you're setting up some bank account or
something
and it's like there are regulations that
say you've got to really verify there's
a person that's the person
you think it is and so there's a there
are various
kinds of ways of doing that and the
various tests
and you know some of those tests say
things like
uh look at the camera now turn to the
left now turn to the right
and you'd have to have this sort of
three-dimensional thing
that is kind of like simulating your
head turning the left turning to the
right and so on
and that's just something that is a bit
out of reach for our current
uh automated systems at the present time
and it's kind of like we can recognize
that face oh yes
you know if you you know hold up your
passport or your driving license or
whatever it is
um and the system the automated system
can see the picture on your
on your driving license and then it says
uh you know and then it can recognize
is this person who is looking at the
camera the same as the person in
on the driving license then okay turn
your head well that's a hard thing to
achieve to make a realistic
sort of head turning thing at least in
the current state of machine learning
and so on although
it's not that far away i suspect and
there's a question then of and will you
be able to see a signature
if in fact that's a fake if the kind of
head
turning thing is just well i got a
picture of the person from the web and i
kind of synthesized what the 3d view of
their head would be and now i'll just
synthesize a turning head
and you know can you tell whether that's
a fake
or whether that's a genuine there's a
real object there and it's somebody
turning their head
um that's something that is uh
um is is difficult um
um to um uh
um uh to deal with sorry one second
um the uh uh
reminds me of another kind of thing
which is
you know part of the how do you tell who
the person is
is you know in two-factor authentication
that's very common
it's like you you know you know your
password you remember your password
oh do you really have that phone that
uh you were you said you
had this particular number can you
really get this particular text message
and type it in
and the sort of more elaborate versions
of that for financial kinds of things
like
that the system will transfer a few
cents to some bank account of yours
can you log in and see exactly how much
it transferred those kinds of things
um i think that uh uh i mean this
question of
uh can you sort of verify uh
that you are who you say you are and so
on that's a
it's a tricky thing and at the present
time there are decent technologies for
doing that
um i think that ultimately one can
imagine
uh terribly intrusive technologies for
doing it
i mean in at the present time there's uh
well there's a lot of
face recognition or more like head shape
recognition
that's becoming common like on on i
think well certainly iphones
i don't know uh other cases there's
you know what's what's happening is
there's some grid of infrared light
that's projected by the phone and
depending on sort of where those
lines fall that gives you kind of the
overall three-dimensional shape
of a head and then that's a way that the
phone can tell is
is that the is that the head that's my
owner so to speak
or not um and that's a uh
and then it can sort of open up and and
they've been other versions of that with
uh um that don't work quite as well with
fingerprints
and so one that's that's considered to
be pretty good is retina scans
the uh the particular pattern of blood
vessels on the back of our eyes
uh when our eyes develop um they
are gradually filled with blood vessels
and those blood vessels sort of
just uh kind of grow out and sort of
tree out
um to sort of fill the space and they do
so in a kind of random way
and everybody has a different pattern of
blood vessels on the back of their eyes
and so you can if you look into
somebody's eye and you can see that
the the retina you can you can see those
blood vessels there
you can also look at features of the
iris on the eye you know
everybody has slightly different
patterns of their iris on
on their eyes that's another thing you
can do to kind of recognizes
this person is that this person or that
person now of course you can say well
this is the iris scan but uh you know
does that
oh and you can worry about you know is
this person
like like um some of these things with
with fingers it's like well i could just
get a
a you know like like happens in the you
know some of the
the uh um action adventure movies you
know there'll be some
somebody will get somebody to touch a
glass or something
and then um they'll uh get their
fingerprint from that and then they'll
use that fingerprint for some kind of
biometric
uh thing of course the test against that
is does
when you put your finger on something uh
is it the right
is your finger the right temperature and
is there a heartbeat there
can you detect a heartbeat and uh so you
know those things make it
more and more difficult to sort of have
the fake finger kind of thing
but uh you know i think if the question
is
uh is there going to be a way to tell oh
that's really this person not that
person
you know it by sufficiently intrusive
things sure you'll there's more and more
you can tell for example one thing you
might tell
if you could get some dna and it's still
too slow and too
too complicated to sequence the dna but
if it's like
you know lick this thing okay there's a
little piece of your dna
that gets in there um now you know you
go and you sequence the dna and you've
got those six billion base pairs
even much less than that is enough and
you can say
this is this person with this particular
collection
of genetic program this particular
genome sequence
and you can then see you can see this
with
with
surprising effectiveness in the net of
the hundred billion humans who've ever
lived
this is kind of their genealogical
relationship you know
there are these ancestors these children
these grandchildren
etc and you can kind of fill in that
whole net
of people and certainly one can imagine
a situation
in which it's like a little piece of dna
and it's like okay this is where this
person fits into the net of all people
i mean i i i'm i have to say i must i'm
a little bit of the uh
uh just leave us all alone and and let
us get on with what we want to get on
with
um so it makes me a bit nervous to think
that one could sort of
place people so precisely and you know
this is this person this place in this
place
and so on i mean sometimes these things
don't work out as badly well
sometimes they work out very badly so
maybe i i
i would say that um uh yeah i mean i
i think that this question of is it the
case that
one will you know
i think the thing that kind of goes
against several of these things is
right now most of what gets done by us
on the web
is us doing it the bots that we have
are much less powerful and effective
than us ourselves i mean sometimes
people will
you know bid in auctions in online
auctions and instead of them as humans
you know pressing the buttons and so on
to bid they'll have a program a bot
that's going and doing the bidding for
them and the question is as time goes
forward
will more and more of what we do on the
web or something
be not us directly doing it but like oh
just have my bots do that for me
you know i've got a little army of bots
that are staying awake when i'm asleep
the bots are at work
you know making uh uh figuring out
whether to
like these posts on some social media
thing
based on their kind of bot conclusions
based on things that sort of i as the as
the human in charge have said
um anyway much much to say probably
about that
um and but i think it is time to wrap up
for uh today um
and uh i thank you um all for lots of
interesting questions and i see lots
more that um
i'll hope to be able to address another
time
so thanks for joining us